Why British Singers Lose Their Accent When
Singing
Mick Jagger, Elton John, Rod Stewart, Ed Sheeran,
Phil Collins and George Michael all grew up
in or near London and have very recognizably
British accents.
Once on stage, they sing like someone who
grew up in New England rather than old.
Yet another example is Adele, who has a lovely
speaking voice, a very heavy cockney accent,
yet her singing pipes do not indicate her
dialect.
One might argue that Adele’s speaking and
singing voices were two different people if
listening without visuals.
Going beyond the British, we see the same
thing with other non-American musicians, such
as the Swedish band ABBA, and many others
singing in English, yet from various places
around the world.
It seems like no matter where you’re from,
if you’re singing in English, you’re probably
singing with an American accent, unless you’re
actively trying to retain your native accent,
which some groups do.
There are several reasons we notice accents
‘disappearing’ in song, and why those
singing accents seem to default to “American”.
In a nutshell, it has a lot to do with phonetics,
the pace at which they sing and speak, and
the air pressure from one’s vocal chords.
As far as why “American” and not some
other accent, it’s simply because the generic
“American” accent is fairly neutral.
Even American singers, if they have, for instance,
a strong “New Yorker” or perhaps a “Hillbilly”
accent, will also tend to lose their specific
accent, gravitating more towards neutral English,
unless they are actively trying not to, as
many Country singers might.
For the specific details, we’ll turn to
linguist and author, David Crystal, from Northern
Ireland.
According to Crystal, a song’s melody cancels
out the intonations of speech, followed by
the beat of the music cancelling out the rhythm
of speech.
Once this takes place, singers are forced
to stress syllables as they are accented in
the music, which forces singers to elongate
their vowels.
Singers who speak with an accent, but sing
it without, aren’t trying to throw their
voice to be deceptive or to appeal to a different
market; they are simply singing in a way that
naturally comes easiest, which happens to
be a more neutral way of speaking, which also
just so happens to be the core of what many
people consider an “American” accent.
To put it in another way, it’s the pace
of the music that affects the pace of the
singer’s delivery.
A person’s accent is easily detectable when
they are speaking at normal speed.
When singing, the pace is often slower.
Words are drawn out and more powerfully pronounced
and the accent becomes more neutral.
Another factor is that the air pressure we
use to make sounds is much greater when we
sing.
Those who sing have to learn to breathe correctly
to sustain notes for the right amount of time,
and singing requires the air passages to expand
and become larger.
This changes the quality of the sound.
As a result, regional accents can disappear
because syllables are stretched out and stresses
fall differently than in normal speech.
So, once again, this all adds up to singing
accents becoming more neutral.
So at this point, you might be wondering if
the musicians actually know they are losing
their accents when they sing.
Working in radio, I’ve contemplated how
accents seem to disappear over my 20-year
career.
Keith Urban isn’t British, though fans of
the Aussie singer swoon over his speaking
voice (many women could listen to him read
the dictionary) and have noticed that he sounds
more American when he sings.
I have spoken to Keith a few times and decided
the good-natured Keith wouldn’t mind me
posing the question: How is it you sing differently
than you talk?
(Certainly not wanting to offend Keith, I
began with a few genuine compliments admiring
his genius guitar skills.)
He took it all in stride, laughed, then responded,
‘I don’t know.’
(More like kneh-owww) ‘Good question,’
he said.
Though I don’t think I have an accent.
I think you do!’
It’s quite reasonable to believe that a
Hoosier like me sounds a bit hillbilly to
a guy from down under.
Keith could not really explain the mystery
behind it, and instead went on to explain
why he was wearing black toenail polish the
last time I chatted him up in person.
(His wife, Nicole, has since been his inspiration
to stop, he says.)
So it would seem, that at least with this
sample size of one, the artist in question
is not aware of any accent change when he
sings.
So what about others?
Andy Gibson, a New Zealand researcher at AUT’s
University Institute of Culture, Discourse
& Communication also believes the change in
accent between speaking and singing is not
a deliberate one, nor are artists even aware
of the change.
A 2010 study he conducted of singers with
speaking accents showed indeed that they were
not aware that they sounded any different;
they felt they were singing naturally.
Crystal says it is unusual for a singer to
hold a regional accent through an entire song,
resulting in what he calls ‘mixed accents’
for most.
And then there’s Kate Nash, the anti-norm.
The English-singing sensation was an unknown
until Lily Allen mentioned her on a MySpace
page and now she boasts more than 100,000
followers on twitter.
She didn’t know she had talent until she
picked up her first guitar two years ago,
and the rest is history.
Nash has garnered success on the music charts,
accent and all, and flat out refuses to even
attempt to sing with an American accent.
She makes no apologies for her background
and even themes her lyrics toward an English
audience.
She is as English as tea in the afternoon
and proud of bucking the trend that so many
British artists seem to follow, whether intentionally,
or more likely in most cases, not.